[Musique]
du 22 février au 1er mars prochain se
déroulera le salon international de
l'agriculture porte de versailles à
paris
depuis trois ans le village réunion
était mis en place une initiative du
département de la réunion qui vise à
valoriser notre île et nos produits
alors je crois que c'est une aubaine
pour nos exposants
je pense notamment à la filière thé à la
filière est également des produits
transformés puisque nous avons su
sceller un partenariat avec les
établissements leclerc normandie qui
aujourd'hui avec la complicité de
leclerc réunion permette de faire
remonter des produits transformés de la
réunion par même des produits frais
comme l'ananas dans plus de 100 magasins
leclerc en handi donc ça montre bien qui
a une belle opportunité
il faut savoir la saisir et surtout se
dire que nous les cas pas une vitrine de
la réunion qui s'inscrit également dans
le cadre du plan agréé pays 2030 qui
vise à élaborer un cap stratégique pour
notre agriculture pour les 15 prochaines
années et la promotion de l'agriculture
passe par ces rendez vous nous devons
effectivement soutenir le monde à
l'école localement pour qu'il puisse
mettre des produits sains et de qualité
dans les assiettes des foyers
réunionnais mais aussi faire la
promotion au niveau national et
international pour que les produits de
niche que nous avons les produits à
haute valeur ajoutée puissent se
retrouver sur des marchés métropolitains
dans certaines raffineries dans
certaines pendant cette âme certaines
boutiques que nous pouvons avoir au
niveau métropolitain
donc il est important que nous
accompagnons ce monde agricole vers la
montée en gamme vers des produits de
haute qualité en partenariat avec la
région liberté le syndicat du sucre et
la chambre d'agriculture le département
permet à 28 entreprises réunionnaises de
participer au salon sur un espace commun
de présenter leurs produits au grand
public et aux professionnels
c'est la troisième fois qu'on a
l'honneur de participer à ce salon
c'était un très grand un gros événement
et on est en est fier de diète au salon
il ya beaucoup de contacts
on a beaucoup d'ouverture on trouve pas
mal de partenaires soit métropole et ça
ne permet aussi de valoriser aussi né le
les productions locales et de valoriser
leurs galettes saucisses par exemple est
bien pour nous c'est ce que tu bénéfique
on espère avoir des contrats peut-être
des gens qui sont intéressés parce que
non on représente aussi la jeune et aux
roms pour le foie gras et on espère voir
des producteurs de foie gras qui sont
intéressés par le produit est aussi
peut-être des épiceries fines ou la
grande distribution qui sont intéressé
aussi par nos crèmes de canne à sucre
pour nous c'est une opportunité parce
que tout seul on n'aurait pas pu
participer au salon moi personnellement
ça fait dix ans que je me suis installé
en tant que
agricultrice et ça fait que trois ans
que je peux participer à ce salon grâce
justement aux partenaires ça nous
apporte plus de
visibilité souhaité dans notre travail
et moi depuis
que je participe au salon par exemple
j'ai des partenaires de plus en plus et
moi ce que ce qu'on veut surtout c'est
d'avoir aussi des partenaires en
métropole qui en train de se faire parce
qu'il ya par exemple le groupe leclerc
depuis l'année dernière qui sont
intéressés à travailler avec nous
surtout avec la farine de bananes le
budget prévisionnel de cette opération
pour 2020 s'élève à 669 1000 euros dont
550 mille euros financés par le
département
[Musique]